Більше половини мешканців окупованих територій -
за Донбас у складі України.
Про це свідчить дослідження
берлінського Центру східноєвропейських та міжнародних студій,
який проаналізував громадську думку
по обидва боки лінії фронту на сході України.
Отримані дані заперечують
поширений міф про те, що українській владі та суспільству
не варто боротися за повернення
захопелних територій, бо їхнє населення, мовляв,
абсолютно проросійське.
35% мешканців так званих "ЛНР" і "ДНР"
бачать майбутнє регіону у статусі
автономії у складі України, а майже 21% -
як і раніше, в межах Донецької та Луганської областей.
Загалом понад 55% населення окупованого сходу -
за Україну.
Натомість приєднатися до Росії хотіло б менше половини -
44,5%.
Причому більшість з них - за автономію
у складі РФ. На противагу цьому серед донеччан
зі звільнених територій мріють про Росію менше 9%.
А 91% - переконлива більшість -
вважають Донбас українським.
Проте є питання, щодо яких обидві частини Донбасу
солідарні.
Це несприйняття курсу на вступ України до Євросоюзу
та НАТО.
Проти членства в ЄС - 72%
мешканців підконтрольних Києву територій
та майже 82% - непідконтрольних.
"За" - суттєво більше.
До НАТО на сході України ще менше симпатій.
"За" членство України у цьому військово-політичному альянсі -
17,5% донбасьців
зі звільнених районів і майже 7% -
з поки незвільнених.
72,5 та 93% відповідно.
Радше об'єднує жителів Донецької
і Луганської областей і ставлення до мінських угод.
45% тих, хто живе
під владою сепаратистів,
і 35% жителів неокупованого Донбасу
байдуже до домовленостей.
По обидва боки лінії розмежування люди більше вірять у "мінськ",
аніж не вірять. Цікаво, що
повністю підтримують мінські угоди
більше жителів окупованих регіонів, аніж неокупованих.
Для свого дослідження німецькі фахівці
обдзвонили та розпитали загалом по 1200 людей
по обидва боки лінії вогню.
Німецькі дослідники запевняють, що
провели опитування за усіма міжнародними стандартами.
Утім, визнають, що не знають,
за яких умов на запитання телефоном відповідали люди,
що перебувають на окупованих територіях.
Висновок Центру
східноєвропейських та міжнародних студій: попри війну,
жителі розділеного Донбасу мають схожі погляди з багатьох питань,
які відрізняються від позицій
населення в інших регіонах України.
Крім того, донбасьців значно більше всього об'єднує,
аніж роз'єднує.